rania el hallouj croyait bien pouvoir
récupérer sa voiture saisie par la
société d'assurance automobile du québec
en s'adressant au tribunal plus tôt
cette semaine mais elle a subi une
rebuffade à laquelle elle ne s'attendait
pas à des fins 339 jobs
suite à ce meeting de 6/4 on attendra
moslem de normal la juge eliane à
marengo de la cour du québec a
immédiatement ajourné la séance
trente minutes plus tard elle est
revenue et a déclaré ceci à nos cinq
espèces de grenouilles
la juge a souligné que les règles
prévoient que les gens soient
convenablement vêtus en cours et que
madame est la louve ne l'était pas elle
lui a demandé de retirer son hijab dans
paris madame mais la louve a quitté la
course sans pouvoir être entendue dès le
départ de personnalités 1,19 des sports
et wii xbox every body and we like est
vrai pas du tout les spectateurs ou de
la juge en chef elizabeth corte on
indique qu'il n'existe pas de directives
quant au port de symboles religieux en
cours
il revient à chacun des juges d'exercer
sa discrétion sur ce qu'il est
convenable de porter en cours tous les
juristes consultés sont d'avis que la
juge il y en a marre 1 go a confondu un
certain nombre de principes
d'abord les symboles religieux ne sont
pas interdits en cours et puis si
d'aventuré une charte de la laïcité
était adopté ce ne sont pas les
bénéficiaires des services qui seraient
visés par une interdiction mais bien les
représentants de l'état comme les juges
par exemple ici isabelle richer radio
canada montréal